welcome to zo playing until our toe from
Finland until art oh come on oh I
dissipated that one okay so i go bishop
it sell my pet line it's fun i'm in just
just a short while there'll be m this
new book released by Victor Borge on
polygons Lopez and he would have two
lines in the in the Rue exchange and one
of the especially Sabbath which is kind
of interesting that's a line that has a
bad reputation but that I that I'm
playing and yeah curious to learn chat
below gone on is giving them for black
what what ideas okay so he wants to open
up the position that's a good idea so
maybe I can deter them a little bit with
Bishop g4 making still go D for my old
setup here is very slow well it's that's
good news so differently like sure if
possible okay
what I wanted to say is preventive for
possible that didn't didn't really work
okay takes Knight takes e4 nuts you
force my idea
so I'm checking Oh other too surprising
isn't that a bit a bit too meek hmm
maybe it isn't my night doesn't have
many squares but he definitely has one
going to play instant boost the whole
time yeah I know just as such an easy
game for everybody besides me I always
have to think about moose and as we have
seen a numerous occasion that doesn't
help me to think about them so what is
this equal maybe yeah this should be for
us a bit but annoying sometimes or some
f5 maybe f5 I'm not sure about this
could be it could be wrong this idea
try to be a bit more active
see for maybe two going c4 and no
mmm takes takes King g5 got the more
active King in that hand gambit kinky
523 g5 I should be okay should be okay
for me I cannot go i cannot go kinky
five hit me six is hanging oh my god huh
I really hate it yeah one movers and now
I have this rotten endgame yeah King
comes up and everything King can go all
the way back back all the way to age 6 m
maybe I can try what is going back why
are you doing that you try to track my
night might work I have to take any way
I mean otherwise I'm doing no matter
what so King t54 possible before
so can see two before now it doesn't
really help that much a five Kings into
a for King be to a be three just about
holding if I consider a foretaste takes
can be true and that's it hmm don't time
morning I would save it and would be for
also doesn't help so I have to go with
this it's losing but what what the heck
man maybe they're still it's still the
slight issue we should be four though
yeah i can go bishop you for that wins I
guess
and see point would also just promote on
it so on this is theirs is the problem
can just go Bishop g7 and twins
nanking be too I Maya playing badly
pretty bad stuff yeah come on yeah black
resigns it's pretty bad to lose that and
Kim when nothing happened it's just a
completely nothing happens and game yeah
whatever night have seven or whatever
you see better what this bishop maybe is
yeah I'd simply did not see be 6i exam
this is why I went through t4 it's just
terrible I have to play something like
that or here I mean I will up late King
c6 intending to take I can also go g6
here so it's just it's just nothing
happens here yeah that's that that is he
is making those moves this is not
leading to anything it's just equal at
best for why my king is more active yeah
it should just be a draw the only thing
I have to avoid is what I did this is
just I'm just going to lose i guess this
king 25 hmm okay so taking how is better
yeah well this way i actually get around
down that's it that's at least better
than the game and the engine gives me an
advantage you but there is slight one i
think it raw is very lightly somehow
no idea cannot play this that's provides
probably a draw where he's making this
this moose it's probably a draw that is
also the fair result of that very talent
game the only way to not make it down or
spit I played it just blundering giving
away stuff yeah okay thanks for watching